collagen it's a protein and a pretty
cool one at that
due to its structure it possesses many
functions within the body that exploits
its strength firmness and elasticity
collagen is found in your skin cartilage
tendons ligaments blood vessels eyes and
while many parts of the body as collagen
is one of the most abundant proteins in
the body
and along with its abundance in our
bodies there is a growing abundance of
research papers on collagen one of which
we'll discuss today a new collagen
replacement therapy that was applied to
the skin of mice and improved long-term
treatment of photo aged skin
so first we'll look in more detail at
both the structure of collagen and where
it is found in the skin and then I'll
show the methods used in this paper to
deliver collagen and the data they
present showing whether it worked and
then we'll have a discussion
so let's take a look at the skin
collagen was recently estimated to make
up 20 to 40 percent of protein in the
skin and the Skin's important people may
simply think about skin for aesthetic
reasons but skin is more than just
Aesthetics it's a barrier it protects
our insides from the outsides which
contain pathogens and chemicals and it's
also a medium of communication with the
environment touch
so our skin is a warrior and other
threats to the skin includes damage by
UV irradiation that can cause photo
aging where the skin prematurely ages
and becomes fragile
amongst many things this is
characterized by loss of collagen
for the purposes of this video then we
need to appreciate the role of collagen
in the skin so where is it well the skin
can be split up into three main layers
the epidermis the outer layer that is
composed of many layers of cells the
dharmus where you can find fibroblasts
blood vessels nerve fibers and the
extracellular Matrix and then beneath it
is the hypodermis the hypodermis
contains more blood vessels and fat
cells
type 1 collagen is primarily found in
the dermis where it aids in building a
fibrillary structure within the
extracellular Matrix that allows cell
adhesion and migration through the
Matrix
this figure shows us how embedded in The
Matrix of the Damas it also provides
support and tensile strength so just to
clarify there are many different types
of collagen type 1 collagen as I just
said builds a fibrillary structure
and is found in the dermis of the skin
you gave from one protein chain of type
1 collagen the so-called Alpha chain and
three of these Alpha chains can come
together to form a triple helix and then
these heel C's then align and cross-link
the foam fibrils so you get strength in
numbers
and it's type 1 collagen that is
commonly seen to get depleted following
photo aging
so a potential solution to mitigate
against this is collagen replacement
therapy
now what you are probably most familiar
with at the moment are collagen protein
powders that you can consume I've not
looked into the effectiveness of these
powders in this video but let me know at
any point if you would like to do for me
to do that because instead we're going
to focus on the latest new technology
delivering collagen mRNA directly into
the skin as explained in this recent
paper
so it's a form of gene therapy and this
is not just to prove if this delivery
modality works but if it does it could
offer a longer term solution and a more
effective way for controlling a skin
aging
so for that cargo then they opted for
the MRNA of cold1a1 this is read by the
cell to make alpha-1 type 1 collagen so
there's type 1 collagen that encodes Pro
Alpha chains that as we just saw can be
combined with other Alpha chains to form
a triple helix that can then go on to
form these fibrils
so the MRNA is that intermediate between
the gene that's encoded in DNA and the
final protein which in this case is the
type 1 collagen
so then the second question is how are
they going to deliver this collagen into
the dermis of the skin and then how
would they test if it was effective
well there are a couple of
characteristics that you would look for
for in Vivo Gene delivery so Gene
delivery here being the MRNA you would
need the vehicle to be large enough to
carry the cargo in this case the MRNA
for coal 1a1 and you'd want the cargo to
be efficiently taken up by the cells and
for the MRNA to get expressed so going
from the collagen mRNA to collagen
protein and you would want this all to
happen without causing some immune
response or toxicity
the two methods compiled in this paper
are extracellular fascicles and lipid
nanoparticles
now we could have a whole conversation
about how I should be saying fascicles
or physicals so I'll just save some time
and call them EVS from now on and these
UVS have emerged recently as promising
carriers for genes in the form of mRNA
as they are naturally secreted by cells
and are therefore biocompatible and have
proteins already present at their
membrane that could facilitate uptake
into the cells of interest and they're
also big enough to carry the cargo
the actual challenge with EVS is
generating enough of them from cell
lines and secondly deciding when to add
the collagen mRNA
Hundley though the team behind this
recent paper previously develops an
approach that's enabled them to
incorporate a high abundance of mrnas
into their EVS called cellular
nanoporation great
and so the other method are lipid
nanoparticles these nanoparticles can be
artificially generated and are lipid
nanoparticles so that's what it is and
many of you are probably already
somewhat familiar with the technology
because it was used by Madonna and finds
a bioin tech for the covered vaccines
and so lmp's these lipid nanoparticles
are easier to manufacture and
standardize plus unlike the EVS it's
known pretty much what's inside of them
because you're making them yourself they
don't come from cells that could be
doing various things
so we have EVs and we have lmps both
loaded with mRNA for coal 1a1 but which
one is better
[Applause]
I'm joking but we did need to have a
model to test if that system was working
so the model system that they use in
this paper was to photo age the skin of
mice and this has been done previously
and done in this paper by basically UV
irradiating the skin and has previously
been shown to depletes collagen in the
tissue and to reduce the thickness of
the dermal layer
and then they wanted to assess the
therapeutic potential of these collagen
EVs and also the lmps and so they did
that and they also had a look as
controls empty EVs and empty lipanani
particles and they also took a look at
retinoic Acid topical treatment
as well as having their negative saline
control
so if we look at the saline control
first we can see that there was an
increase in a number of wrinkles
following this treatment with UV
irradiation showing that the skin had
indeed been photo aged
sorry I probably should have pre-warned
about the number of miles back sides
you're about to see
um
but regarding the therapeutic approaches
you can see here that the Eevee with
coal 1a1 performs best in terms of
reduction and wrinkles but the lmps were
Auto effective and both approaches
demonstrated higher elasticity and
firmness following the UV irradiation
but mice delivers the lmps showed
redness and swelling while the EVS did
not exhibit a strong inflammatory
reaction
so it looked like the EVS before the win
but not yet as the effect bought off
after a month as the wrinkles reappeared
so to enhance the long-term reduction in
wrinkles the authors modified their
delivery to use micro needles designed
to improve the duration of protein
replacements so did the signed
hyaluronic acids microneedle EV
formulation
these patches they made were pressed
onto the back skin of the mice and it
dissolved into the tissue without
visible skin irritation and it was the
best strategy they found for recovery
after photo aging the skin it
substantially reduced wrinkle number up
to 70 days
but it's just above me mentioning here
before I forget that they did do this in
a thymic mice with an inhibited immune
system what the immune response would be
in a mice with thymuses I'm not entirely
sure but anyhow the authors concludes
the intradermal delivery of EV base coal
181 mRNA may make for an effective
protein replacement therapy for the
treatment of photo age skin
there are a few things worth discussing
before we end though
firstly EVS without the coal 1a1 mRNA
actually achieved a modest decline in
wrinkle number
and that's likely because these empty
EVS are well they're not really empty as
they contain content that originally
came from the source cells
what these endogenous cargos are is not
only interesting but probably important
to find out since otherwise they don't
know 100 what they're giving to the mice
and this would be very important if this
approach was going to be translated to
human Therapies
and speaking of human Therapeutics using
this approach the author States although
many challenges would need to be
overcome before the micro needle-based
EV delivery system could be tried in
humans because of the improved
biocompatibility and benign side effects
profile of EVS as compared with lmps and
adeno-associated viruses we believe that
the system might constitute a universal
nucleic acid carrier for the treatment
of a range of human diseases and
conditions
moreover the coal 101 mRNA when in these
EVS were stable at room temperature also
making it amenable to clinical utility
but it is important for me to reiterate
that this delivery modality shown in the
paper is not the same as taking collagen
as a supplement what happens when
following oral consumption is not
something I've actually looked into yet
so to conclude EV sees astrocellular
fascicles seem like a promising
technology to keep an eye on but right
now you should put your eye on this
video YouTube recommends for you with
that I hope you've learned something in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening